let's talk about your friend tris pryor
really out of anybody that she could
talk to i know tris moore because i've
been on the run with her and i was with
her all through dauntless training so i
know her strengths i know her weaknesses
that's not like you're gonna shoot me
why do people keep saying that
an insurgent you really start to see him
kind of
question this person that he's been and
he is a bully to chris and
he doesn't necessarily enjoy it and in
this movie he does a good amount to try
and fix that
i don't think peter knows the answer to
whether he's a an ally or an enemy i
think he really just cares about
himself he just turns outside whether
you mention or not
if you want to survive make sure we do
he is such a a survivor that he will
always figure out where he needs to be
in order to be safe he may be dauntless
but i'm not just a meathead
no offense max
peter goes on a true arc i mean he
starts one way
he starts stabbing people in the eye and
by the end of the movie you realize that
he doesn't really like himself and that
these actions that he's doing
is just a manifestation of some
you know deeper issue that he's just
avoided
i don't think i was supposed to tell you
that
oh well
what's next for peter i hope he gets his
own spin-off would be called rock and
roll pete just pete rocking out hardcore
once a week thank you go with happiness